why was the star wars holiday special a
disaster what possessed lucasfilm to
make an ewok movie filled with death and
murder keep watching to find out
blowing up the death star at the end of
1977's a new hope wasn't just about
saving the galaxy it was about our two
main characters fulfilling their arcs
han solo had spent his life living up to
his last name he was in it for himself
and had no interest in anybody who
wasn't paying him but after meeting luke
skywalker and obi-wan kenobi and helping
them reach the rebel base he found he
couldn't keep looking the other way he
returned at the perfect moment taking
darth vader out of the fight and giving
skywalker the chance he needed to save
the day luke meanwhile had to learn to
embrace the spiritual world of the force
and east's ties to the physical world
he's known all his life and once he did
that he was able to make the impossible
shot and destroy the death star han
solo's daring return showed that this
scoundrel could become a hero and luke
proved that he had what it took to
become a jedi someday
released in 1978 the star wars holiday
special was many fans first chance to
return to a galaxy far far away and it
was a doozy a two-hour
made-for-television variety special the
film followed chewbacca as he and han
solo try to make it home in time for
life day most of the special follows the
various ways chewbacca's furry family
passes the time waiting for chewie's
return and most of its cameos from other
star wars characters come from the
wookie's wife mala as she calls her
husband's friends and asks about his
whereabouts they all assure her that
he's on his way there unfortunately the
empire is convinced of the very same
thing and hopes to use the holiday to
capture han and chewbacca imperial
stormtroopers search the wookie's house
and leave a soldier to wait for the
rebel's arrival but with the help of a
local trader sympathetic to the rebel
cause they managed to kill the soldier
with the imperial soldiers out of the
way the wookie family takes crystal orbs
that sort of look like snow globes lift
them over their heads and somehow use
them to spiritually connect with the
main cast and many other wookies they
stand around the tree of life in red
robes while leia sings a strange strange
song then everybody leaves and the
special finally ends the 70s were weird
you guys no matter how different we
appear we're all the same in our
struggle against the powers of evil and
darkness
what a new hope built up 1980s the
empire strikes back would seemingly
change forever but the climactic battle
on bespin was less about the empire and
more about luke finding his path while
training with yoda luke once again is
urged to embrace his growing connection
to the force and let go of his
attachments this time however the
attachments that luke has to discard are
his friends who have been captured by
imperials in cloud city luke refuses to
abandon them but ultimately his decision
nearly gets them all killed which would
have also doomed the entire galaxy luke
paid a heavy price for his decision he
discovered that vader was his father
lost his hand his lightsaber and even
his best friend he also placed all of
his friends in the very danger he had
hoped to save them from by the time the
credits swoop the heroes are on the run
and things look bleak indeed
while the empire strikes back it may
have been the rebellion's darkest period
1983's return of the jedi proved to be
one of its brightest after freeing han
solo from jabba the hutt luke skywalker
and the rebel alliance discover two
things leia organa is his sister and the
empire created a second death star above
the forest moon of endor our heroes race
to save the galaxy again but there's
just one problem it's a trap
yes emperor palpatine set the whole
thing up to both destroy the rebellion
and seduce luke to the dark side all at
once but he was wrong to believe that he
could convince luke skywalker to join
the dark side of the force instead luke
having learned his lesson at last
restrains his emotions lets go of his
anger and spare us his father this leads
to vader's redemption the emperor's
death and with a little help from some
furry new friends the salvation of the
galaxy never underestimate a jedi or
anyone
speaking of ewoks in 1984 george lucas
experimented with television once more
and released a made-for-television movie
called caravan of courage an ewok
adventure on abc starring the
recognizable ewoks of endor the story
follows the human toani family after
they crash land on the forest moon and
attempt to survive the parents end up
kidnapped by the gorax forcing their
children sindal and mace to work
together with wicket and the ewoks to
rescue them after a long journey across
deserts acid pools and giant mountains
the children overcome their fear reach
the gorax's fortress fight giant spiders
and with the help of the fairy like
wisties free their parents ultimately
gorax is defeated in the ensuing battle
by essentially tripping him into a giant
chasm and the victorious heroes return
to the ewok village to celebrate their
victory and mourn those they lost it
seems like a happy ending but about that
in 1985 fans got their third star wars
film in just as many years when another
spin-off named ewoks the battle for
endor aired on abc and it was strangely
horrific in a twist beginning more
suited to the alien franchise than star
wars before the tuany family can fix
their ship and go home space marauders
led by a knight sister of dathomir kill
them all well except sindal who manages
to escape with wicket and hide with an
old hermit after the night sister
kidnapped sindal the hermit noah and
wicket managed to infiltrate the castle
free the ewoks steal the parts and use
them to repair noah's ships and defeat
the marauders with its defenses with the
ewoks free and the threat finally over
sindal goes with noah so that she can
return to the galaxy at large as endor
is not her true home so what does it all
mean
endor sucks that's what
when it finally hit theaters in 1999 the
phantom menace was the first star wars
film in over a decade armed with
state-of-the-art cgi that was simply
impossible when he finished the last
film george lucas sought to finally
finish his six-part saga by revealing
the story of anakin skywalker and the
clone wars that he had teased all the
way back in 1977. the entire film boils
down to palpatine engineering an attack
on his own planet of naboo so he can
convince naboo's ruler queen amidala to
declare a vote of no confidence in the
republic's current supreme chancellor
allowing palpatine to replace him
everything else that happens in the
movie is essentially a distraction that
allows him to succeed even the
impressive duel of the fates between
qui-gon obi-wan and darth maul if
qui-gon survived his experience and
outlook as both a jedi and a teacher may
have been enough to keep anakin from
falling to the dark side later on but
because maul struck him down before
being defeated himself obi-wan is forced
to train and as we will see ultimately
failed the young boy 2002's attack of
the clones was the moment that many fans
had been waiting for since 1977 when the
clone wars were first mentioned in a new
hope once again the plot is about
palpatine manufacturing a crisis in
order to gain power his sith apprentice
count dooku leads a war of secession
from the republic which allows palpatine
to create his own clone army in response
as the senate gives him ever more power
to combat the supposed threat if that
wasn't enough palpatine had also
recognized the incredible power within
anakin and begun grooming him to be his
future apprentice and most powerful
weapon he became the boy's friend in the
decade between the two films and used
that connection to subtly encourage
skywalker to embrace the dark side and
act on it as he does with the tuscan
raiders it's an incredible sinister feat
of political engineering that would
prove very successful and oh yeah there
was also a bunch of lightsaber fights
secret marriage the first battle of some
war and the birth of a future bounty
hunter named boba fett yoda apparently
turned into cgi and jumped around a lot
too those things were fine but the
politics are really where it's at
from the moment the prequel trilogy was
originally announced fans of the
original films knew how it had to end of
course with the status quo we see at the
start of a new hope and 2005's revenge
of the sith is the tragic moment where
it all comes together having used the
clone wars to slowly but surely grant
him near total control of the entire
republic palpatine finally decides that
he's ready to finish his master plan
with anakin now on his side he
eliminates count dooku and defeats the
separatist army then executes order 66
forcing every clone to rebel against
their jedi generals and kill them
obi-wan and yoda are among the only
survivors obi-wan confronts anakin and
defeats him but this traumatic event
simply finishes the transition of anakin
into darth vader darkness falls across
the galaxy as it waits for the arrival
of a new hope
the prequel trilogy would find its own
spin-off film in the 2008 animated film
star wars the clone wars set in between
attack of the clones and revenge of the
sith this theatrically released film was
essentially the pilot project for the
television series and helped fill in the
gaps between the two movies the plot
involves jabba's son being abducted and
a ploy to keep him from allying with the
republic against the separatist army in
the end this ploy fails but the real
meaning behind the events of the clone
wars was the introduction of anakin's
apprentice ahsoka tano her arc which
would be explored in the clone wars
series was a mirror of anakin's own
journey allowing us to see through her
eyes what may have happened if he had
chosen a different path the path she
herself ended up choosing that is merely
hinted at in the film of course but the
seeds are planted here
a decade after the prequel trilogy
concluded disney released star wars
episode 7 the force awakens in 2015
after purchasing the franchise from
george lucas for 4 billion
at the film's climax the mysterious
newcomer rey gets captured by kylo ren
leia and han's mostly evil son and held
on starkiller base the newest iteration
of the death star han chewie and finn
fly to the base and attempt to rescue
her before general leia organa and the
resistance can destroy the base with
them still on it after rescuing rey han
tries to reach his son one last time but
determined to follow the path of his
grandfather darth vader kylo rejects his
father's plea and murders him kylo ren's
story is a mirror image of the arc of
his mentor luke skywalker when luke had
the chance to kill his father darth
vader he spared him rather than turn to
the dark side but kylo ren decided to
kill his father and embrace the dark
side setting up the central conflict at
the heart of the new trilogy
the ending of the 2016 new hope prequel
rogue one probably needs less
explanation than any of the others
because the entire movie was retrofitted
to make sure it ended exactly where a
new hope begins recall that in a new
hope luke is able to destroy the death
star because secret schematic smuggled
out by rebellion spy showed a design
flaw that made the death star vulnerable
rogue one was built to explain how such
a glaring design flaw existed in the
first place and how the rebel spies got
the information it turns out that the
death star designer galen erso
intentionally built in the weak spot as
part of his revenge against the empire
and his daughter jyn erso was the one
who delivered it to the rebellion at the
cost of her own life father would have
been proud of you
the film ends with those plans being
delivered to princess leia whose ship is
attacked by darth vader exactly as the
opening sequence of a new hope showed
four decades earlier
if jj abrams the force awakens was the
reestablishing of what fans had always
remembered star wars to be then ryan
johnson's 2017 sequel the last jedi was
an examination of the franchise that
seemingly attempted to deconstruct its
tropes and storytelling after kylo ren
fails to turn rey to the dark side she
flees to a nearby planet where the last
remnants of the rebellion are being
hunted down by the first order it all
seems doomed until luke skywalker
unexpectedly shows up after abandoning
his jedi ways following the loss of his
student kylo ren to the dark side luke
has seen the error of his ways thanks to
rey's devotion to her friends it's no
coincidence that the middle film of the
new trilogy culminates in the same
decision as the middle film of the
original trilogy just as in empire
strikes back the student in this case
rey chooses to leave training to save
her friends against the direction of the
jedi master this time it's luke who pays
the price rather than han but once again
the surviving heroes escape on the
millennium falcon to fight another day
2018 solo a star wars story was in a way
the first star wars origin story it
showed fans how han got his last name
escaped his home planet of corellia
trained as a storm trooper met chewbacca
for the first time and won the
millennium falcon from lando calrissian
in a game of tsubak by keeping the man
from cheating the story is
self-contained and clever but it
introduced a lot of plot threads that
still haven't been picked up on to this
day most notably the big screen return
of darth maul to the land of the living
as a crime lord the ending was designed
to set up more sequels or prequels
depending on how you look at it but
because of poor box office returns none
of those plot threats have yet been
picked up since
just as the original trilogy was
fundamentally about luke skywalker's
journey the new trilogy was about kylo
ren's battle against his own dark nature
so it was fitting that the climax of
2019's star wars episode 9 the rise of
skywalker concluded with the end of his
story more conflicted than ever about
his dark side decisions after sensing
his mother's death being healed by rey
and imagining a conversation with his
father han solo kylo ren finally gives
in to the light side of the force and
becomes ben solo once again this is
echoed by rey's discovery that she is a
descendant of the evil emperor palpatine
but rather than continue the age-old
battle between their two families kylo
ren chooses to sacrifice his life to
help rey defeat the reborn palpatine the
threat ended rey returned to tatooine
and buried luke and leia's lightsabers
before officially taking on their name
to honor them in many ways star wars
episode 9 the rise of skywalker ended in
the same place that return of the jedi
left its heroes with the emperor's death
reigniting hope for a new democratic
government and a reborn jedi order led
by a powerful hero with her own original
lightsaber
like the original trilogy had the ewok
adventures and the prequels had the
clone wars the sequel trilogy has
received its own official specially made
spin-offs in the form of 2020's the lego
star wars holiday special the feature
focuses on ray skywalker's attempt to
train finn in the ways of the jedi
though both are struggling with the
prospect in an attempt to gain guidance
she travels to a temple on cordoku to
observe a special life day ritual that
ultimately allows her to travel
throughout time and meet star wars
characters from multiple different eras
including luke yoda qui-gon jinn obi-wan
kenobi and darth vader who once again
turns to the light at the end
hey what's with the sweater
after nearly breaking time by giving
vader and kylo ren access to the green
crystal that she was using to traverse
the time stream rey sets everything
right with the help of several versions
of luke skywalker and learns her lesson
life day is about spending time with
friends and family
the second of legos made for disney plus
original specials 2021's lego star wars
terrifying tales follows poe dameron as
he crash lands at vader's castle which
has been turned into the first
all-inclusive sith inspired luxury
resort it's run by grabala the hutt
whose creepy caretaker vinay begins
telling post stories in an effort to
trick him and a young boy named dean
into retrieving one of vader's holocrons
as they go dean and poe bond over their
shared rough childhoods but vinay
retrieves the holocron and uses it to
form and power a massive exoskeleton
dean uses poe's x-wing to get it back
but vinay captures poe and holds him
over a cliff in order to deliver his
ultimatum hand over the artifact or
watch poe die though the boy is almost
overcome with fear dean finds his
courage and throws the holocron over
vinay's head and into the lava below
binet catches the device but falls to
his death in the fire below while bb-8
successfully catches poe and saves him
from the same fate afterward poe forces
the hutt to close his hotel putting dean
out of a job so that poe can take him to
rey to train in the ways of the force
however as they all leave a mysterious
hand and a laugh reach out from the lava
showing that vinay has survived to be
continued who knows what the next star
wars movie will bring us check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you